字幕: Koichiro YODA
校正: Kyoko Kamura
まず最初に
私が20歳の時に経験したことを
みなさんにも感じて欲しいなと思います
20歳 私は大学３年生でした
みなさんは何をしていますか？
成人式行きました？
はい 行きました
ありがとうございます
健康診断 この前ありましたね
その健康診断で医者に
あなたはこう言われます
「うーん ちょっと
気になる点がありますね
明日 大学病院に
行ってもらえますか？
私の方で予約を取っておきました
いいですか？明日必ず
大学病院に行くんですよ」
いきなり明日ですよ
そう言われてもと思いつつ
その医師の気迫に押され
あなたは明日
大学病院に行きます
そこでは 様々な検査が
待っていました
その検査の後 その大学病院の
医者がこう言います
「んー ちょっと
やっかいな病気ですね
早めの治療をした方が
いいと思います
３ヶ月？その程度でしょうか
休めますか？」
一昨日までは
なんでもなかったあなたは
いきなり厄介な病気だそうです
「厄介な病気
何ですか？」
（医者）「うーん がんです」
20歳のあなたは
がんになりました
さぁ 私のプロフィールを
少し紹介しましょう
今のように私は
20歳の時にがんになりました
そもそも 私は
「二分脊椎」という障がいを
持って生まれてきた人間です
歩き方がおかしい
そして杖をついている
体が小さい
これは この二分脊椎という
病気によるものです
20歳で精巣がんの治療をして
薬に興味を持った私は
大学卒業後
製薬企業に入ります
そして その企業を辞めた後に
「ペイシェントサロン協会」
という会を立ち上げ
その代表をしています
それとは別に２年前に
今度は 甲状腺がんになりました
もう こちらのがんは
治ることはありません
一生がんと付き合っていく
そういう人生を
余儀なくされた人間です
日頃は 製薬企業や大学などで
研修や講演活動をしています
今日は「患者と医療者の
心の距離を近づける」という
これからの医療のあり方について
お話をしたいと思います
がんの治療をしている私は
医療の現場でいろんなことを思い
そして考えました
「大学３年生で３か月休んだら
留年しちゃうじゃないですか
大学に早く復学したいんだけど」
言いたいなと思いました
でも 言えませんでした
「え？髪の毛抜けちゃうんですか？」
聞きたいなと思いましたが
聞けませんでした
「医療費どのぐらい
かかるんだろう？」
こういう 知りたいなと
思ったことすら知れませんでした
当時 付き合ってた
彼女がいますが
「彼女にどう説明すれば
いいんだろう？」
相談したいなと思いましたけど
相談できませんでした
「医療の現場って
患者の立場で入ると
言いたいこと聞きたいこと
口に出せないな」
でも それって全部
自分のことですよね？
あなたは 病院に行ったとき
そういうことを思ったときは
ありませんか？
「医療って遠いな」
そんな気がするんです
製薬企業に入った私は
いろんなことを学びました
その中の１つに
「患者中心の医療」
という考え方があります
医者や看護師や薬剤師
あるいは製薬企業も含め
いろんな職種の方が連携をして
チームになって
患者さんのために頑張りましょう
でも この絵を見て
言葉を聞いて
違和感はないですか？
もっともっと—
身近な例を
考えてみたいと思います
みなさんにお尋ねします
この中で花粉症の人います？
ああ いますね！あ 結構いますね！
ありがとうございます
花粉症の人どうでしょう？
アレルギーの症状で
くしゃみや鼻水が出たら
病院に行って
そうすると医者が
「うーん あなた花粉症ですね
じゃあ 薬出しておきましょう」
満足ですか？
そもそも花粉症は あまり治せない
病気かなと思いますけれど
その病気の付き合い方って
様々あると思うんです
たとえば
「今週末 屋外で
彼女と初めてのデートです
だから 今週末なんとか
くしゃみと鼻水止められませんか？」
という方もいるでしょう
「いやいや もう今
仕事忙しくって
24時間やっている
ドラッグストアの薬で
なんとかしたいんです
平日の昼間しかやっていない
この病院にはなかなか来れないんですよ
いい薬を紹介して下さい」
という方だっているでしょう
「いや もうアレルギー辛くって
何年かかってもいいから
体質を改善したいんです」
そういう方だっているでしょう
要は あなたはどういう医療を
受けたいんでしょう？
あなた自身がそれを考えて
それを口にしなかったら
医療というのは
本来 始まらないものなんです
いや これはね
医療だけの話じゃないんですよ
そもそもとして
あなたは どういう生活を
送りたいと思っていますか？
そこにつながる話なんです
「あなたは 今 どういう生活を
送りたいか？」と聞かれて
きちんと言葉にできますか？
20歳の私には
それができませんでした
さきほど私は 患者中心の医療と
この絵を見せまして
違和感があると言いましたけれど
本来 あなたも
医療者と同じ輪の中に入り
あなたがどういう医療を
受けたいのか
それを医療者に言う
そこから医療というのは
始まるはずなんです
これを私は
「患者中心」じゃなく
「患者協働の医療」
というふうに言っています
患者協働の医療において
必要なこと
それは何かと言ったら
「対等な立場」
医療者と患者は
対等な立場であり
そこに本音の対話が
あるということです
この対等な対話というのは
医療者の意識を
変える可能性があります
今までは あなたの
症状にしか興味がなく
病名をつける
それが医療だと
思っていた医療者
だけれども あなたが根底に考える
そもそもどういう医療を受け
どんな生活をしたいのか
この情報を医療者が
得ることによって
あなたに寄り添った医療を
提供できる可能性があるのです
それにより 今まで
遠いなと思った医療は
少し近くの医療に
なるかも知れません
例を挙げてみましょう
がんの薬は
抗がん剤と言いますが
抗がん剤を打った私は
一晩にして髪の毛が
全て抜けました
かわいい？
失笑
（笑）
あぁ いいですよ
一晩で 今あるこの髪の毛が
こうなるんです
あなたが今 この髪型になったら
どういう気持ちになりますか？
今日ここに来れますか？
「電車の中の他の人の目が痛い」
「隣に座っている
お友達になんて言おう」
そういう気持ちになり
外に出れないかもしれません
そうなんです
この髪の毛が抜ける
これが辛いんじゃないんですよ
髪の毛が抜けることによって
周りの人との関係性が
崩れていく
変わっていく
これが怖いんです
もし 医療者にそこまで
言うことができたら
この医療者は どういうふうに
対応するでしょう
今は 単に「この薬打ったらあなたの
髪の毛抜けますよ」という話です
だけれどもあなたが
「周りの人との関係性が
壊れるのが辛い」
その気持ちを言ったならば
「では この髪の毛が抜けた後に
すぐ使えるようにウィッグ—
カツラですね
じゃあ ウィッグを
用意しておきましょうか」
「頭のサイズを測るんです
ウィッグ作るときに
だけど今は髪の毛がある
だから１センチ引いて
小さなサイズにしてくださいね」
そんな話ができます
医療じゃないですよね？
だけれども
患者に寄り添った医療というのは
そういうことじゃないでしょうか
このように
患者さんや医療者が
対等に対話する場が
もっともっと普通に
欲しいなと思いました
私は 医療者ではありませんので
民間のこういうカフェを
借り切って活動を始めました
月に１回「ペイシェントサロン」
と名付けて活動したんです
ここには その時の１枚の
写真を持ってきましたが
ここに医者がいて
薬剤師がいて
理学療法士という
医療者がいて
看護の学生がいて
そして 患者がいます
１つテーブルを囲んで
みんなが本音の対話をしています
毎回テーマを決めています
たとえば「医者と想いを共有するには
どうしたらいいんだろう？」
「どうやって病院を
選んだらいいんだろう？」
毎回毎回 いろんなテーマを
置いて対話をするんです
立場が違う人から経験 意見
知識 アイデアが出されます
お互いにお互いが気付き合う
学び合う そういう場です
今月で80回を迎えました
開始して80ヶ月ということです
色んな感想や意見が聞かれます
医療者の側からは
「患者さんの疾患だけじゃなくって
もっともっと 想いを
聴きたくなりました」
「診察室で治療法を一方的に
言っていたかもしれないけれども
患者さんの生活を考えた
治療法を一緒に考えます」
「もっともっと患者さんの生活を
そして医療への想いを聴くって
いいなと思いました」
そんな声が寄せられます
患者の側からも
様々な声があります
「そっか 自分の想いを
診察室で語っていいんですね
そして それが大切なんですね」
そんな感想もあります
「普段 どんな生活を
期待しているのか
望んでいるのか
そんなことは
考えたときがなかった
だけれども そういうような
ことが大切なんですね
この場で考えさせられました」
本当に様々な意見が寄せられます
こうやって 活動も
回を重ねていくと
「私もやりたい！」
「一緒にやりませんか？」
そういう人が何人も現れて
ペイシェントサロンという活動を
私がいつも借りている
カフェだけじゃなくて
皆さんの地元でも
やるようにしよう
そういうふうになって組織化したのが
「ペイシェントサロン協会」です
今 私はこの会の
代表をしているわけです
ここでは ペイシェントサロンの
具体的な手法を学んでいただいて
それをご自身の
ペイシェントサロンとして
自宅の近くで開催していただく
そういう活動をしています
と言いつつ まだ全国で
たった８か所しかありません
「もっともっと各地で
広げていきたいな」
希望を持っています
あいにくこの神戸でも
まだ開催されていません
いつかこの地でもペイシェントサロンが
できたら嬉しいなと思っています
このように 患者協働の医療
そして対等な対話をする場
それが全国に広がったら きっと
今まで「医療が遠いな」と
感じたその気持ちも
少し近づくんでは
ないでしょうか
でもね
そういうのって文化を
変えるっていうことです
なかなか すぐに
できるものではありません
ですから今日 ここにいるみなさんに
お願いがあるんです
まずは あなた自身が
どういう生活を送りたいと
考えているのか
それを考え
そして 口にできるように
なっていただきたいんです
そして 私のように
がんになったり
あるいは 治りにくい
花粉症になったり
そうなったら あなたが
どういう医療を受けたいのか
勇気を出して医療者に
伝えて欲しいんです
医療者は あなたのその一言を
待っているんですよ
今 健康な時だからこそ
考えていただきたいんです
その言葉を医療者に伝える
その一言が
患者と医療者の
心の距離を近づけるという
これからの医療の
在り方ではないでしょうか
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）